surely flying can't get more comfortable
to cannon don't call me shirley
accidentally falling asleep on a fellow
passengers shoulder will be a thing of
the past that is if Boeing's patent for
a transport vehicle upright sleep
support system is approved Boeing's
invention dubbed cuddle chairs by
GeekWire will consist of backpack like
contraptions that passengers can pull
out from under their seats to rest their
head and chest on making comfortable air
travel accessible to all alright so
basically the future it's a fine line
between flying on an airplane and
[ __ ] a robot that seemed like what
it's going to be I want to do this story
because when we've done stuff about
planes I don't like to fly in general I
always every time I've ever flown
whether drugged or not I have a moment
thinking that that's it you know I mean
and it's all over and did i do
everything right and all that but we've
all had the people sleeping on us we've
all sat in the middle all that so this
is this is pretty good this is a nice
little something you want to be strapped
in when when they get you would you like
to be strapped in to the seat you don't
want to be strapped in that's scary that
does not look comfortable first and
foremost yeah like this is not a great
way to sleep I especially like when
you're traveling you know here to New
York or something six hours of this yeah
no um stop trying to squeeze more chairs
in and make all the seats tiny and then
you won't have to make a cuddle chair
right making chairs that you have
actually comfortable so is that one
wrong just one right so is that really
is that really the thing here that they
want to squeeze every dime out of us so
the steeps keep getting smaller and now
they're gonna strap us in I mean it
works into our favor to I mean the more
people that can fit on a plane that
cheaper tickets are gonna be yeah that's
already pretty expensive that us as it
is so I would trade that the money for
any sense of comfort anyways for some I
can't yeah but I mean because six-hour
flight what even like leaning up against
the side of the window like fall into
the aisle or sleep on that somebody I
don't know like I try to sometimes sleep
on the tray table which never really
works out but I curl up into a little
ball anyways and normally make it work a
little bit but I feel like that that
would I know i wouldn't mind like you
know yeah like I'd like put my knees up
and then kind of like I don't know that
be comfortable have you guys ever had
like one of those really bad experience
we've all had the kid crying kind of
thing or someone kick in your seat but
have you ever had something really
I like someone sleeping on you or like I
just I flew this week there was someone
within three rows that was farting
constantly you know and we're trapped in
a tin up there you know and I just
wanted to open the door a little just
let it out of something that would be
something cuz I'm a friend Heather you
know each you did who blows up planes
every time not that way yeah thanks okay
seriously like a-- they need an
invention for that for her ass or all
asses like that like some sort of
cushion that would that would just
absorb it yeah or send it back into her
that's weird um have you ever had one of
those just like terrible flying just
something yeah it seems like I always
get stuck in the middle people who like
to like really lean over on their side
of the arm chair so that I'm like
sitting in the middle kind of like this
like not sure like if I want to eat
something I kind of have to like to like
one of these types of maneuvers yeah so
yeah I wouldn't mind a cuddle chair cuz
then I could at least like lean forward
and avoid all of that yeah but it seems
kind of gross honestly two at the same
time cuz everybody's like cuddling with
the same thing yeah and then you put
your face in the hole like even whenever
I go to like if I have to go to a
chiropractor or like a massage thing
whatever you put your face and it hits
like I always kind of hesitates it
grosses me out especially people sleep
they drool so what are you like I could
look after your face well sure there's
gonna be some kind of disposal no
disposable not outright I don't know
anyway what do you think are you
comfortable on airlines as is do you
like the guys sleeping on your shoulder
have you ever met anyone that way let us
know in the comments right now